IT.
SHE WAS 96 YEARS OLD AND WE CAN
MISS HER.
WE WILL SEE YOU BACK HERE
TOMORROW NIGHT, TUCKER IS UP
NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
TODAY WAS A BIG WIN, OR SEEM TO
DEMOCRATS GAVE TO THEIR DEMANDS,
THE GOVERNMENT IS BACK OPEN.
DETAILS ON THAT AND JUST A
THE FBI WITH STUNNING
REVELATIONS ABOUT THE HILLARY
CLINTON REVELATION.
EVEN IF YOU THINK YOU KNOW A LOT
BUT FIRST, FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
ON THE SHOW WE HAVE DISCUSSED
OUR COUNTRY'S IMMIGRATION
POLICIES.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY NIGHT WE HAVE
ASKED SUPPORTERS OF OPEN BORDERS
HOW CAN YOU JUSTIFY THIS?
TO AMERICAN CITIZENS BENEFIT
FINALLY FROM MSNBC COMES AN
ANSWER.
ON OUR WE CAN SHOW THIS
SATURDAY, ANCHOR JOEY READ
INTERVIEWED A GENEALOGIST WHO
HAD DONE HISTORICAL RESEARCH ON
MY FAMILY.
FROM SWITZERLAND.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT UNTIL
THE SHOW AIRED BECAUSE I HAVE
ZERO INTEREST IN THE SUBJECT.
I WAS MORE THAN 150 YEARS AGO.
IT IS IRRELEVANT TO THE
DECISIONS THAT I MAKE AS A
FATHER OR AS A CITIZEN OR AN
ABOUT OUR MODERN IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
AMERICA'S ECONOMY HAS CHANGED
QUITE A BIT SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
ACCORDING TO MSNBC, THIS FACT IS
A CONVERSATION AND ARE.
A SINGLE 19TH CENTURY SWISS
RELATIVE MEANS YOU ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO SUPPORT GREEN CARDS
FOR EVERYONE WHO JUMPS THE
BORDERS OR OVERSTATES A VISA IN
2018.
BOOM, CASE CLOSED!
ANSWERED JUST PUT IT, PEOPLE IN
GENEALOGICAL GLASS HOUSES
SHOULDN'T THROW STONES.
MEANING ME.
AS IS SO OFTEN THE CASE, IT'S
HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHETHER
WAS PART OF AN ELABORATE PARODY,
MONTY PYTHON DOES DACA.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT
ABOUT THE SINCERITY OF WHAT CAME
NEXT.
HERE'S JOY REID'S RESPONSE.
SHE WASN'T JOKING AT ALL.
WATCH.
>> TUCKER HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE AT PUTTING
FORWARD WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN IS A PRETTY BLATANTLY
WHY SHOULD NATIONALIST VIEW OF
WHAT IMMIGRATION SHOULD BE LIKE.
>> Tucker: JOY REID IS
ACCUSING US OF RACISM.
LET'S PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND
SAVOR THE IRONY OF THAT.
REID'S ENTIRE PUBLIC CAREER HAS
BEEN BUILT ON THE RACE BAITING.
TRY TO WATCH HER SHOW FOR
20 MINUTES AND SEE FOR YOURSELF.
VOTES WEREN'T WORTH FIGHTING
FOR.
THAT WAS LAST AUGUST.
IN OCTOBER SHE SUGGESTED THAT
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN
KELLY WAS SOMEHOW A BIGOT
BECAUSE HE GREW UP AROUND IRISH
CATHOLICS.
AFTER HOUSE MAJORITY WHIP STATES
THE LEASE WAS SHOT AND NEARLY
KILLED BY A PROGRESSIVE ACTIVIST
LAST SUMMER, REID OPENLY
WONDERED IF WE SHOULD HOPE FOR
OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE IS WISHING
THE CONGRESSMAN WELL AND HOPING
THAT HE RECOVERED, BUT STEVE
SCALISE HAS A HISTORY THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN FORCED TO SORT OF
IGNORE ON RACE.
HE DID COME TO LEADERSHIP AFTER
SOME CONTROVERSY OVER ATTENDING
A WHITE NATIONALIST EVENT, WHICH
HE SAYS HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT
AMEND THE CONSTITUTION TO DEFINE
MARRIAGE AS BETWEEN A MAN ON THE
WOMAN.
BECAUSE HE IS IN JEOPARDY AND
EVERYBODY IS PULLING FOR HIM,
ARE WE REQUIRED IN A MORAL SENSE
ACCUSES YOU OF HARBORING RACIST
THOUGHTS, TRUST ME, IT'S
PROJECTION.
IT'S ALSO A POLITICAL TACTIC.
REID CAN'T EXPLAIN WHY THIS
NOBODY ON THE LEFT CAN EXPLAIN
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S NO REAL
ANSWER, SO THEY ATTEMPT TO
SHORT-CIRCUIT THE CONVERSATION
WITH SLAYERS.
IT DETERMINES WHO LIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY, WHO CHOOSES OUR
GOVERNMENT, WHO SHAPES OUR
FUTURE.
IT'S HARD TO THINK OF A
PUBLIC-POLICY TOPIC MORE CENTRAL
TO EVERYTHING.
WE TRIED OUR BEST TO DISCUSS
MOST OF THE TIME WE SUCCEED, NOT
WITH WHAT WE THINK OUGHT TO BE
DONE.
CLASS OVER FOREIGN COUNTRIES,
CONGRESS OUGHT TO BE RESPECTED
WE BELIEVE THAT AMERICA IS AN
ACTUAL PLACE, NOT JUST IN
OUGHT TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND
INCREMENTAL.
WE OWE THAT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY LIVE HERE, PEOPLE OF ALL
REMAKE OUR SOCIETY WHOLESALE,
ESPECIALLY JUST SO A SMALL GROUP
CAN FEEL VIRTUOUS OR HAVE
CHEAPER NANNIES.
ANY CHANGE IS HARD.
IF DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE ESPECIALLY
IT ALWAYS HURTS THE WEEK AND
ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE FIRST.
SOMEONE OUGHT TO BE THINKING
ABOUT THEIR INTERESTS TOO.
THOSE ARE OUR VIEWS.
THEY ARE NOT EXTREME AND WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THE
WITH WHAT WE JUST SAID.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT, LOOK UP
THE VIEWS OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY ARE NOT WHAT JOY REID, TO
PUT IT MILDLY.
THEY KNOW WHAT THE COST HAS
BEEN.
THOSE WHO DISAGREE WITH ANY OF
US ARE ALWAYS WELCOME HERE.
THIS IS THE ONLY SHOW ON
TELEVISION THAT BOOKS GUESTS
EVERY NIGHT WILL HAVE A
YOU CAN LISTEN TO BOTH SIDES ON
THEIR SHOW AND YOU CAN MAKE UP
YOUR OWN MIND.
DEBATE.
THEY BELIEVE IN POWER,
ACCUMULATING IT, AND MOST OF
THAT DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
WHAT WAS ONCE A DEVASTATING
ATTACK ON A PERSON'S CHARACTER
IS NOW JUST BACKGROUND NOISE.
WHEN EVERYTHING IS RACIST FROM
THE TERM HAS BEEN DEVALUED BY
RECKLESS OVERUSE, AND THAT'S A
SHAME BECAUSE IT STILL APPLIES.
THERE'S STILL PLENTY OF RACISM
IN AMERICA, MAYBE MORE NOW
POSSIBLY THAN IN GENERATIONS.
AMERICANS ARE ATTACKED OPENLY
FOR THE RACE EVERY DAY IN PRINT
COME ON TELEVISION, AT PUBLIC
GATHERINGS.
PEOPLE ARE PUNISHED FOR THEIR
RACE IN HIRING, COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS, GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE CONTRACTING.
THE LEFT SUPPORTS ALL OF THIS.
IT IS CENTRAL TO THEIR
WORLDVIEW.
IT IS KEY TO THEIR POLITICAL
WE STILL BELIEVE IN WHAT USED TO
BE THE CENTRAL PREMISE OF
AMERICAN LIBERALISM.
PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE JUDGED ON
WHAT THEY DO, NOT ON HOW THEY
LOOK OR WHO THEIR PARENTS WERE
OR WHAT THEIR ANCESTORS DID.
IF WE DON'T BELIEVE IN
COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT OR REWARD.
IMMIGRATION POLICY OUGHT TO BE
DRIVEN BY WHAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
CAN ADD TO AMERICA.
NOBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO BE
ADMITTED BY LOTTERY, OR BECAUSE
THEY HAPPEN TO BE RELATED TO
SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY HERE OR
BECAUSE THEY SNUCK IN AND IT'S
TOO POLITICALLY DIFFICULT TO
MAKE THEM LEAVE.